Oh what is going on my little nipple
stains now for a lot of us when we think
about working out we think about a
couple ways of doing it which is always
running or it's weightlifting now for me
out of those two is the one that I
prefer it has always been weight
training but as you guys all know I hurt
my back so I had to go to alternative
forms of exercise that's right [ __ ]
the type of workout that I have now Stu
come to is swimming and let me tell you
something about swimming
it is hard as [ __ ] you know funny enough
before I actually started to do this as
an exercise I talked a lot of [ __ ] about
it and the reason being is because I was
using like Batman excuse logic meaning
like you know whales swim all the
[ __ ] time and they fat as [ __ ] so you
know why would that work and now that
I've experienced swimming as an exercise
I'm gonna go put this out there anybody
who says swimming is not a hard exercise
and when you stupid his [ __ ] and I'm not
talking about laying on your big ass
back and floating I'm talking about 10
to 15 active laps back and forth panting
and you know on the verge of throwing up
that wasn't me though I was fine I was
like I'm gonna tell you something right
now if you ever wanted to impress a girl
in the gym swimming is not the way to do
it when I swim I sound like I'm
constantly being scared by somebody you
know what my biggest pet peeve is in the
gym when you share in the pool is when
somebody goes in the sauna and they
don't watch themselves off before they
jump the sweaty ass into the pool that's
[ __ ] disguise do you have any idea
what parts of your body is moist before
diving into that water how are you gonna
jump into a community pool smelling like
a direct anus the moment people jump
into the community pool your ball sweat
is all up in our purses wow look that is
just common sense nobody should have to
tell you that people don't want to taste
you when they swim you're sweaty piece
of elephant children whoa I said and yes
I understand that there are other
alternatives besides swimming and just
you know the gym pool but for a good
chunk of us out there the pool gym is
the most easily accessible pool out
there for us to use somebody told me
once because I live
la I should just go swim in the ocean
because it's natural I got so much time
out of my day to go drive 30 and 40
minutes to the coast just so I can go
swim in the [ __ ] ocean [ __ ] get your
life together
I think a lot of people confuse how
close people in LA lived in the water
this isn't Hawaii [ __ ] and even
if it was I'm not gonna be in the ocean
for like an hour let me tell you
something if I was in Hawaii floating on
the coast for an hour my ass can get
eaten by a shark like that you have
obviously not seen you shirtless in the
water because I look exactly like a
wounded seal watch a shark by me in the
water and be like oh look at that
big-ass white belly I honestly have no
idea how Michael felt does this as a
living that shit's [ __ ] crazy it's
the power of white people at the ferry
Christopher Columbus didn't come on a
ship that [ __ ] just swam across
so for a small portion of you out there
if running hurts your joints or if
you're afraid to get trade physically
with weights then try swimming on its
gentle other joints is tiring as [ __ ]
and I guarantee if you do it for a good
long period of time you'll be burning
their [ __ ] Canada babies for me
people has been hard to switch at my
workouts when weight training to
swimming just because you know I like
weight training as a form of workout I
feel like I get a better burn and it's a
lot more fun and exciting for me but I
had to make adjustments and I can't
complain and I gotta keep on trucking
forward so I'm using swimming as a form
of exercise so for those of you out
there that are looking for different
types of workouts I don't know try
swimming it's worked for me it tires me
the [ __ ] out and even you know the next
morning you know parts of my body or
sword then I didn't expect I wasn't
using my nipples Miami nipple sword so
I'm never for this BAM
until next time remember life is what
you make it but it's up to you to take
what you deserve let's go for broke aah
Oh what is going on YouTube that
concludes another episode of funny bad
fit if you guys are wondering about
wearing this shirt right now is because
I want to see if I can fit I could have
been it before and yeah I fit it now so
progress is progress and I feel and
looked a lot better than I did before
that's why people love me love me love
but anyways recently I went for a show
out in Colorado did some stand-up and I
met a couple of funny fat fit members
and guess they have progressed they lost
weight and I got to tell you something
man that made me so happy to know that
people out there were doing it with me
and they were seeing results so I just
want to remind you guys just to keep it
up I will do this as long as I have not
reached my personal goal which I will
reach eventually and I will do it
because if I don't it's pretty [ __ ]
because I have all these videos so
remembers the spring line of gopher
growth is going to drop this month very
very soon so for every one of you that
want that you know the winter floral
patterns you know what is gone it's gone
so get it while you still can and the
spring line is gonna be dope so fitness
BAM yes I will see you all next
Wednesday and hopefully you guys will
keep up keep on hashtag me funny fat fit
and let me know how your promise is
going even if I don't respond to you I
am reading it I feel a little bitty
sometimes so see y'all next time
what's up this is my foot y'all didn't
know I'm loving one pants Oh make that
booty showed you a little ass there huh
got you hey that's right [ __ ] the one
huh well I keep on calling y'all [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] to your [ __ ] ball set
your ball set you know because you got
two sets of balls you know just for them
just dangling around like a little
change purse you yes let's do that [ __ ]
yo tell metell next type in this dough I
just spit all up on this place what's up
so one dude broke